okay i think it's safe to say that ryan
reynolds is a real life superhero at
this point
the actor is using his voice for a very
good cause he's asking his followers to
help search for a missing teddy bear
with a
very personal meaning over the weekend a
cbc news reporter tweeted out a picture
of the stuffed animal alongside a
heartbreaking message reading
it was in a herschel backpack when
stolen along with an ipad
mara the owner says it has her mom's
voice inside
saying i love you i'm proud of you i'll
always be with you
her mom died last year and it didn't
take long for ryan to catch wind of the
stolen bear
tweeting out to his 16 million followers
vancouver
five thousand dollars to anyone who
returns this bear tomorrow
zero questions asked i think we all need
this bear to come home
now mara soriano the young owner of the
missing bear
responded to the cbc reporter's tweet
with an image of her and her mom
in a hospice asking that the bear be
returned or anyone with information can
email her
at findmamabear yvr gmail.com
mara's tweet now has over 900 reshares
ryan's tweet has over
93 000 retweets and 325 000 likes
mara also thanked the actor for sharing
her story tweeting
from the bottom of my heart thank you
for that kind message i have been
devastated since the theft and this
message was so heartwarming there is
good in the world
and shit's creek star dan levy also
joined the fight to find the teddy bear
tweeting out
canada please help find this bear now
although the backpack has yet to be
found
mara continues to provide updates on her
twitter and even has surveillance
footage from
two nearby restaurants that supposedly
show the suspect with her bag so
hopefully with ryan's now financial
incentive they'll be able to find the
bag and recover the missing bear that
means
so much tomorrow of course ryan speaking
out about this missing bear comes as no
surprise as he's known for his
humanitarian
side including his continued work with
sick kids
and his and blake lively's numerous
donations to black lives matter causes
covet 19 relief efforts and many more